if Russia were to Nuke a U.S city we
would fire a nuke in return in
retaliation and then the whole world
just blows itself up I don't believe
that's true and I believe that's a myth
and I also believe is it a myth that
there's a second strike capability what
do you mean in other words if we get
nuked we will launch nukes well in other
words what you just identified as you
know
um Preposterous or whatever is the idea
that if we are fired upon with a nuclear
weapon we will fire one back and then
the whole world goes boom isn't it
possible that we clip off the end of
that the whole world going boom and
there's you know do you believe just as
a threshold matter that if we are
attacked with a nuclear weapon we have a
second strike what's called a second
strike capability the ability to launch
the second nuclear strike and retaliate
so there's so I think there's there's so
much wrong with the presumption first
there's that famous story of the Russian
submarine that received word that a nuke
had been launched and the guy in this
one I guess what'd he do he refused to
launch it is the story was that was that
what it was pull that up and get us a
story correct because I I could be
getting it wrong but even when it was
like they have attacked us the nukes are
heading towards us he goes I won't fire
it I won't do it and so that was this
this Legend legendary story or urban
legend whatever you want to call it
historical Legend you know basically he
believed that there was an error because
a lot of Soviet Tech at the time was not
uh was not as you know are you sure that
he believed it was an error my
understanding was that he refused to
fire on even when ordered to I it could
be both but from what I remember that
that story that you're talking about
who's like on I think it was a sub he
was on the sub I believe yeah and he
believed that it was like it was an
error it wasn't the actual it wasn't
actually the beginning of a nuclear war
but it was a movie about this whole
subject Fail-Safe where the American
Pilots have been given word that we've
been attacked and they're reluctant to
be the ones that actually you know but
that's why you have command and you know
you have a chain of command and so on
but his name was Vasily uh alexandrovich
archipov and he refused to authorize the
captain to fire nuclear Torpedoes what
year was that
uh wow I'm surprised I'm surprised it's
not there so there there is a um I think
I I think it was a British MP or someone
in Europe said
you would be insane to sacrifice London
or New York for you know uh Warsaw or
something that if if Vladimir Putin were
to use and especially Kiev if Vladimir
Putin were to use intercontinental
ballistic missiles we're talking
multiple independently targeted re-entry
vehicles with 12 Warheads peppering
every major city in Ukraine
I do not believe anyone in the west
would fire upon Russia with nuclear
weapons and if Vladimir Putin were to
actually fire an intercontinental
ballistic missile at Poland I do not
believe the West would launch nuclear
icbms in retaliation at Russia as they
are legally required to to come to their
offense of that required to come to the
defense does not mean firing nukes of
Civilian targets so so but why is mad so
so mad is mad is a um is a fallacy or is
a is a popular delusion because well I
think it's more complicated than people
think they think that if Russia were to
launch a nuke then like in that movie
was it war games with Matthew Broderick
all the nukes go flying in the air and I
just don't think that's real reality
because the reality of of uh strategy
and war is not that some dude sitting at
a computer and he's like well a nuke was
fired better fire ours but I will say if
it was World War II if the Japanese had
had nuclear bombs that they probably
would have dropped them back on the
United States after
perhaps but those were gravity bombs the
very first nuclear weapons were dropped
out of bombers and after we knew the
capabilities of the Germans knew the
capabilities of nuclear bombs and there
was a rush to to weaponize this and we
got there first the United States
knowing the capability of a gravity bomb
seeing a bomber with with you know
fighters on its wing they'd be like stop
that bomber and we would definitely be
prepared for something like that but we
shouldn't like allow geography I think
to govern our our Assessments in this
area so that if if it's simply the fact
that uh the United States and Russia are
so far away from each other uh and it
would require intercontinental ballistic
missiles for this kind of exchange to
occur uh let's shrink our example to
India and Pakistan okay which you know
are not as far away from each other and
are both nuclear armed which have a
history of conflict with each other okay
uh do you believe that uh mutually
assured destruction Theory uh obtains in
in that re in that theater we need we
need to break down what it really means
in that there is the reality that if if
Vladimir Putin fired an ICBM a mirror
nuclear-armed nuclear a nuclear-armed
multiple independently targeted re-entry
vehicle with 12 Warheads
it goes up into the air ejects 12
Warheads to Pepper the Eastern Seaboard
of the United States the United States
would absolutely fire in retaliation
okay but that is an oversimplification
of what nuclear war likely will be so in
your in your example with India and
Pakistan we're not talking about a you
know seven eight Thousand Mile uh launch
of an ICM into space which we all know
is coming and then be like there it is
and we know it's heading for us we can't
stop at fire
Indian what what I what I think that the
mistake is that when you talk about
nuclear war people only think one thing
an ICBM launching from a silo in the
ground in certain in Siberia or in
Oklahoma and then flying through the air
when in reality what's likely going to
happen is Vladimir Putin when he
escalates to nuclear war is going to
take nuclear artillery uh I'm sorry
artillery and it's probably going to use
lower yield gravity bombs 100 kiloton
maybe even getting to the point of a
Megaton these are much much smaller
these days and attacking Ukraine to to
win if he has to No One In The West is
going to retaliate with a nuclear strike
on Russia if Russia uses nukes to win
the war in Ukraine however our our our
leaders in the present government
including the National Security advisor
at the White House let's say Jake
Sullivan
have have stated many times that they
have communicated to the Kremlin through
the channels they have and they have
them
um that very very severe consequences
would befall Mr Putin and his government
if any kind of nuclear weapon were
introduced into this conflict and and
that's not a U.S retaliatory strike on
Russia right so what would you imagine
would be our most severe uh sanctions
if if Russia introduced the most severe
I'd imagine is a U.S declaration of war
and uh well I mean really could actually
imagine taking place right yeah I think
there's a strong possibility that
Vladimir Putin were to use tactical
Nuclear artillery or small lower yield
uh weapons nuclear weapons and in
Ukraine that NATO would formally declare
war and the U.S would enter the war and
have a strong probably generate a decent
amount of public support if they come
out and say they just use nukes We're
not gonna just the world will not be
destroyed we must stop this madman and I
I think that's that's very likely so
Putin may be concerned that if he
escalate to that point he gives a
Castle's belly to the west to directly
invade and and engage right now it's
it's relatively passive what the US is
doing that being said Putin is not
playing a game to lose and if pushed to
that Brink I genuinely believe he will
be like well it's either I lose now or I
lose against nato in a year fire the
nukes
but we'll see I don't know one aspect of
this is that his military is so depleted
as a result of this
uh catastrophic I don't believe it
misadventure those leaks showed that the
amount of casualties was substantially
less than they've been reporting and
what was it was that supposed to have
been doctored wasn't that the one part
of the document that was supposed to
have been Bulldog of War I I perhaps
perhaps
but I I just think it's fascinating this
idea that Russia which is a massive
economy would have would be losing to
the only country that's become poorer
since the fall of the Soviet Union but
they're not just fighting that country
they're obviously fighting a coalition
that's supplying them and training them
so on U.S veterans and look you don't
have to be a military analyst or
um or have military experience to to to
assess this conflict and to be able to
discern accurately that it hasn't gone
well for Russia and that it you know
what what was the I think the operating
premise of both the Russians and the
West at the start of the conflict was
that it wasn't going to last very long
and that they would if they had the
gumption if they had the nerve to launch
this kind of violence kinetic military
violence in Europe which had hasn't seen
this kind of thing since World War II if
he was willing to cross that line he was
going to have an easy time capturing
Kiev and deposing the zelenski
government well you know Putin's problem
was that he sat back and let NATO expand
for decades and that was Russia's
problem and it's like only now they're
willing to engage in military conflict
they've basically lost at this point
it's it's the craziest thing to me that
you would lose you know 50 of the
conflicted territory and then decide to
fight it's like you lost already bro
well but also they already got your
border with Estonia and Latvia now
you're mad because of Ukraine and gas
prom but also look at the Reliance on
the Wagner group okay which shouldn't be
necessary for world-class military and
who is the Wagner group it you know
they're plucking convicts out of prisons
and throwing them there and even the uh
after the the call-up order that one
went down in September I think it was uh
which met with some extraordinary
displays of resistance on the streets of
Moscow and elsewhere
um you know the reports are that uh and
this is also verified by interception of
uh of signal Communications between
soldiers at the front and their families
and so on but they are throwing even the
the the conscripts into battle with uh
without the sufficient gear making them
pay for their own helmets they can't
even feed them their their quarter
mastership alone has been an absolute
catastrophe we heard the same thing
about Ukraine
that was that that that guy last year or
whatever who tried to volunteer and then
said it was a disaster people need to
have guns and they were like if you
leave we'll shoot you or whatever but we
but we are we ought to be more surprised
hearing it about the Russian military
considering considering but you know I
think you do make the point NATO is it's
basically Russia versus Nato and
Ukraine's being propped up by us thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time